[Music]
in hey it worked news there really
though submitted by angry blobfish
she gets really angry an ex-con held up
two different banks
armed with only impossible oh and he
succeeded that's [ __ ] funny man was it
gun-shaped it's all squishy a minute is
right what if it was like I got a
grenade
maybe yeah that's the only thing that
maybe was a brown avocados are pretty
gross whatever you want man yeah sure
that's [ __ ] brown turns all black into
the key wait so is it a peeled avocado
okay like it's hole but it's peeled yeah
all right so this 47 year old resident
of southern Israel is facing charges of
aggravated robbery after successfully
stealing about eight thousand three
hundred dollars from two banks and he
did it by using an avocado by claiming
it was a grenade it looks like one make
sense yeah
what he did is that he wrote a
misspelled note so he's an idiot
or it was intentional he entered this
Bank that was in a shopping mall and so
he handed the cashier this misspelled
note demanding that she hand over the
cash and so it said hand over the money
in the drawer but the misspelled word
drawer is a hard one drawer in Hebrew
draw or draw were in Hebrew so oh this
was like a Israeli Bank yes okay so this
is an Israel yeah
so when the cashier appeared to hesitate
is when he said put the money in the bag
quickly or or throw this grenade and so
that's when he got away for in that
first bank and then and so from that
first Bank he got away with about four
thousand four hundred and fifty dollars
in cash and a five days later that's
when he decided to rob another Bank and
he's like this [ __ ] [ __ ] work
he blackened avocado avocado himself
genius yeah so you blackened it himself
he made the [ __ ] marks - yeah I'm
like it still doesn't look like if
you're the telethon you're like I came
in looking like a robber though and
they're just waving something around I'd
be like oh [ __ ] how would it be like
that's Agron that's not a grenade us
avocado oh yeah would you be that you
don't mean if you do that and it is a
grenade then that's dangerous yeah
hey that's not a good answer [ __ ]
avocado famous last words young I mean
yeah but you know what - it's like what
are you be killing himself
maybe you throw it over and run out will
he be killing them - yeah be taken away
you could probably run to the door pull
the pin and throw it to say [ __ ] you and
then he'll already be out the door and
they're like wait this is just avocado
yeah and it's just like a bruised
avocado I guess the market doesn't
affect the Enzo thank you people are
robbing banks - they only want money
like they're not going in there saying
like I hope I kill somebody today
they're going in like thinking I hope I
don't have to kill anyone today and
someone just gives me the money so I can
run out with it I mean you would like to
think that because then you'll hear
about mugging stories where they
actually like get the money and shank
the person that's mostly like at
7-eleven [ __ ] yeah like bank robberies
and stuff how often do you hear like and
then people were shot well not very much
they just start shooting when they
realize the cops are closing in they're
not gonna get what they want any freaked
out
they're like I'm taking someone down
with me remember we did that Jay King
news where the security guard as soon as
the bank robber walked in he gunned them
down yeah I replayed that like a million
times crazier he just immediately
reflexively no a guy came in with the
full ski mask and a gun and then he
walked in and as soon as he saw him he
just boom boom yeah imagine it was Bart
trying to surprise his girlfriend gos oh
my god for later on yeah he got murdered
for it crazy so yeah so then that second
bank he left with about 3,300 dollars in
cash
only 12,000 no or that bro yeah you get
away with it the first time and the
second time then that's when police she
did it multiple times police
investigated the security cameras and
that's how they were able to like him
things to get like a shield number on
the avocado label they they had clues to
the man's identity because he in both
robberies he wore hats that covered his
face as well as sunglasses and in one
case an eyepatch I passed this guy's a
bunch of weird [ __ ] in his house why
didn't you just keep using the same
don't think that crimes are connected
that's probably exactly what he thought
well yeah cuz you don't wanna get caught
for two charges so then police tracked
cell phone locations during the times of
the robberies and then they followed
several different leads but then they
finally found the suspect who turned out
to have a criminal record including once
serving a three-year prison term for
robbery back to his old ways but it's
pretty crazy how you got away with it
and just thought oh that must have been
his lucky avocado if I got away with
like a rod Riblet and my favorite don't
ever expire until a week it's done yeah
I got what cuz good bad so fast I know
you have to have like an arsenal of
avocado did he have an arsenal um oh
okay well there we're not things when I
worked at the bank they tell you just go
with it like don't try to be a hero and
try to say just like just give them the
money but then they tell you you have
you always have that explosive ink one
and then they're like just put that in
there too
you always have it there on your top did
you ever have to have a have a robber
there No thank God so every every teller
down the road everyone has like supposed
to be yeah so the way a teller has at
least for Bank of America you have like
your little car on wheels that gets
locked up every single night so that is
yours and yours alone you and the the
manager are the only people that have
keys and you both have to unlock it so I
can never unlock it on my own and then
the manager can never lock down though
so you have your top drawer with all the
small bills then you have the lower
drawer I'm like giving all these secrets
away with all
yeah with all your larger bills and then
the top you never want to have more than
like maybe five grand your top drawer
and then the rest I think total your
whole box is no more than 20 then the
top is where you break up your fear ones
you're just your fives or whatever and
then change or whatever and then you
have that bundle of this might be a
stupid question but how does the
explosive anything work when does it go
I think it's it's parameter based so
once it leaves that Bank it just
explodes on time yeah you know like the
shopping carts that automatically lock
once it you're too far from the store is
it like tied in the money yeah looks
exactly like that I know which one it is
well then you do it oh I'm like that
would be crazy
what if you give it to a customer no no
it's you and you can't you know which
one it is but like if you're getting
robbed like the the person robbing is
not going like which one's the real one
they just want to get in and out is it
actually ruin the whole bag of money
yeah the whole thing is just a bunch of
ink it's just it yeah it explodes
everywhere how is it that much ink to
ruin the whole bag when it's hidden like
that that's the crazy part you know like
in that let me clear out that oh yes
it's literally like this and then they
put like a little device exactly
or is it like they cut a hole kinda like
those books I want to study it accident
I don't know how it works I don't want
to soon it's not working it's like I did
everyone knows that she [ __ ] with the
Blooey cuz her whole face looks like the
blue bag did you play with the fake
money no so it doesn't wash off for like
two weeks because the cops want to catch
you yeah an alarm you set off the alarm
no we all have alarms on our station
like right right like that you everybody
there are neighbors to [ __ ] with them I
hit this you know could they charge you
a lot of money like that's the thing you
have if you set it off oh really
yeah like that's on purpose yeah that
makes sense
imagine you're accidentally like looking
like if you're a disgusting person I
think have to hold it oh four seconds
yeah yeah yes I'll hold it get a sound
alarm right yeah did you ever get to hit
that why the [ __ ] are you doing it like
that
wait what am i doing that was the lamest
attempt ever to do [ __ ] like [ __ ]
jail you know what I was doing honestly
swear I wasn't did you do the [ __ ]
alarm in the movies they do that [ __ ]
they always use two fingers and they go
underneath the desk yes you do you don't
see the fingers at though I see that in
the shot never [ __ ] you never watch
movies Jess can you keep this big guy
let's see Steve actually swear I wasn't
hard feeling I've seen it where you go
like this I wasn't even going for this
[ __ ] man
they go this is like how it felt when I
was trying tell you guys on a certified
scuba diver I believe I believe you have
a beaver trapping certification before
scuba driving one I guess was doing Nick
he's not into Nicky's not think he's
weird I haven't done that [ __ ] in
forever
you just try sticking a finger in her
but I might big ol boys big boy maybe my
pinky just too warm enough maybe bro
that's like the size of a regular person
index finger
my index finger I'll follow you
I'm 6 4 toes Mickey spy for oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's my height she does have a chance
yes littering in here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]